Back toward the end of the 20th century, in the last few months, there was a flurry of last minute scrambling. People trying, for some reason, to document what the 20th century was all about before it ended, as if human civilization was suddenly on a global term paper deadline. We had to get everything down before the semester that was the last century ended. Or there would be points taken off our papers.
20世纪末的最后几个月，人们陷入了一阵手忙脚乱的恐慌。不知为何，大家都在争先恐后地想要在世纪结束前记录下20世纪的意义，仿佛人类文明突然面临了一场全球性的论文截稿日。我们必须在上一世纪这个学期结束前把一切记录下来，否则论文就要被扣分了。
And during this odd period of human beings thinking about the past, and the present, and the future, The New York Times Magazine decided to do a special issue summarizing who we were at the turn of the millennium which it was going to bury in a time capsule for the people of the year 3000. And among the dozens of people who they invited to take part in this, they caught a guy who I know named Bennett Miller, who makes films.
在这段人类反思过去、现在和未来的奇特时期，《纽约时报杂志》决定制作一期特刊，总结千年之交的我们是谁，并将其封存在时间胶囊里，留给公元3000年的人们。在受邀参与的几十个人中，他们选中了我认识的一位名叫本内特·米勒的电影制片人。
The New York Times could include films in the capsule and stills from the films of the frames in the magazine. And they asked if he had any interest in documenting something for the people of the future. As it turns out, just the night before, Bennett had been at a party where he had met this guy who he just adored, really funny, smart guy who was a professional actor and a dwarf, as I understand it, very tiny man.
《纽约时报》可以在胶囊中放入电影作品，并在杂志里印上电影截图。他们问本内特是否有兴趣为未来的人们记录点什么。结果，就在前一天晚上，本内特参加了一个派对，遇见了一位他非常欣赏的男士，那人是个职业演员，非常风趣、聪明，据我所知他还是一位侏儒，个子非常矮小。
And Bennett suggested to The New York Times that he would make a very brief movie, where he would take this guy on the street somewhere and film him alone. And the guy would look directly into the camera and say something along the lines of, "Hello, people of the future. Scientists tell us that by the time that you're seeing this, humankind will have made unimaginable advances. Gone will be the problems that plague us today, disease, inequality, pollution, war. Why, I am told that 1,000 years from now, human beings may grow to be as large as five or perhaps even six feet tall. People of the future, I salute you." And that would be it.
本内特建议《纽约时报》，他可以拍一段非常简短的电影：他会带着这个人去街上的某个地方，单独拍摄他。那人会直视镜头，说出类似于这样的话：“你好，未来的人们。科学家告诉我们，当你们看到这段影像时，人类已经取得了难以想象的进步。那些困扰我们今天的疾病、不平等、污染、战争等问题都将消失。我听说一千年后，人类的身高可能会长到五英尺甚至六英尺高。未来的人们，我向你们致敬。”就这样。
And presumably, the people of the future would at some point look at the other pages in the magazine buried in this time capsule and realize that 20th century humans had already reached five or six feet in height, many of them. And hopefully, they would understand the whole thing was a joke, a joke launched deep into the future, which The New York Times did not go for this. But I have to say, I love this idea. Can you imagine what it would be like to get a message like that from 1,000 years back? If we would find little pranks left for us in the ruins of Egypt, or Rome, or Pompeii, we would love those people.
想必未来的人们在某个时刻查看封存在时间胶囊里的杂志时，会意识到20世纪的人类中，许多人其实早已长到五六英尺高了。希望他们能明白这一切只是个玩笑，一个投向遥远未来的玩笑。《纽约时报》最终没有采纳这个方案，但我必须说，我喜欢这个点子。你能想象从一千年前收到这样的留言会是什么感觉吗？如果我们能在埃及、罗马或庞贝的废墟中发现前人留下的恶作剧，我们一定会喜欢上那些人。
Anyway, around this time, when people I actually knew and loved were worrying about the civilization of the future and what it would think of us, there came a point where I realized, I hate the people of the future. I don't care what they think of us.
总之，大约在那个时候，当我认识并深爱的人们都在为未来文明会如何看待我们而担忧时，我意识到，我讨厌未来的人们。我不在乎他们怎么看我们。
Picture them. There they are, 1,000 years from now, the people of the future. Not only are we dust, but our children are gone, our children's children. Everything we ever believed or cared about, it is long, long forgotten, all of it. And there they are, the people of the future, busy with their busy lives, driving to work, making plans for the weekend, getting together. To hell with them.
想象一下他们吧。一千年后，未来的人们就在那里。不仅我们化为了尘土，我们的孩子、我们孩子的孩子也都消失了。我们曾经相信或关心的一切，早已被彻底遗忘了。而他们就在那里，过着忙碌的生活，开车上班，计划周末，聚会。去他们的吧。
I hate them. I mean, I don't hate them, but they can fend for themselves. And they don't care what we were like, not in a big way. Who do we remember? Name 10 people from the 15th century.
我讨厌他们。我是说，我并不真的恨他们，但他们得靠自己。他们并不真正关心我们是什么样的人，至少不是在宏大意义上的关心。你们能叫出十个15世纪的人名吗？
Lots of people, of course, think differently than I do when it comes to the people of the future. And they have their work cut out for them, worried about their legacy, what will people think of them. And they're trying to set the record straight. They are the subject of today's radio program.
当然，很多人在对待未来的人们时，想法与我不同。他们肩负重任，担心自己的遗产，担心人们会如何看待他们。他们试图澄清事实。他们就是今天广播节目的主题。
From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, preparing for the people of the future. We bring you three stories in three separate acts.
来自芝加哥WBEZ和公共广播国际，《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是：为未来的人们做准备。我们为您带来三个故事，分为三个篇章。
Act One, Dewey Decimal Beats Truman. Bill Clinton is building a presidential library to memorialize himself for the people of the you-know-when. Our own contributing editor Sarah Vowell tours the libraries of four dead presidents to come up with suggestions and tips for how he should handle the job.
第一章，“杜威小数胜过杜鲁门”。比尔·克林顿正在建立一座总统图书馆，为“那个时候”的人们纪念自己。我们的特约编辑莎拉·沃威尔走访了四位已故总统的图书馆，为他的工作提出建议和提示。
Act Two, One And One Don't Make Two in which we hear the story of somebody who, through an accident of history, became obsessed with how the future would view her, Marguerite Oswald, the mother of Lee Harvey Oswald. We have rare audio recordings of her from the 1960s that have never been played publicly.
第二章，“一加一不等于二”，我们讲述了一个因历史偶然事件而执着于未来将如何看待她的人的故事——李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德的母亲玛格丽特·奥斯瓦尔德。我们拥有她在20世纪60年代从未公开播放过的珍贵录音。
Act Three, You Don't Have To Be An Einstein. Mike Paterniti weighs in with this story that begins with Einstein's brain preserved for the people of the future and ends in a karaoke bar. Stay with us.
第三章，“你不必非得是爱因斯坦”。迈克·帕特尼蒂讲述了一个故事，故事始于为未来的人们保存的爱因斯坦大脑，结局却在一个卡拉OK厅。请继续收听。
Act One. If somebody is straight up a hero, the question of his legacy is just not that interesting. It's the flawed people, the imperfect, who have to think hard about how to best present themselves, which is why the question of a Clinton presidential library is such an interesting one. Sarah Vowell has taken it upon herself to offer some advice to the president on how to handle the job.
第一章。如果一个人是纯粹的英雄，他身后事的议题就没那么有趣了。正是那些有瑕疵、不完美的人，才不得不绞尽脑汁思考如何最好地展示自己，这就是为什么克林顿总统图书馆的议题如此有趣。莎拉·沃威尔主动承担起为总统提供工作建议的任务。
Memo, To President William Jefferson Clinton, From Citizen Sarah Jane Vowell, RE Presidential Libraries Fact-Finding Tour. Mr. President, I'm tired. Who wouldn't be after eight long years of sticking up for you? 60% of the American public still likes the way you do your job, but somehow, I never seem to run into any of these people.
备忘录，致威廉·杰斐逊·克林顿总统，来自公民莎拉·简·沃威尔，关于总统图书馆实地考察。总统先生，我累了。为您撑腰八年，谁会不累呢？百分之六十的美国公众仍然认可您的工作表现，但不知为何，我从未遇到过这些支持者。
So I'm excited about your impending presidential library in Little Rock. No longer will I be responsible for defending your honor to friends, family, and the occasional cab driver. What a relief to turn over what's left of my faith in you to some building in Arkansas. But before I relinquish my duties as your crabby, little cheerleader, I scoped out four presidential libraries to help you figure out how to do the job right. Not that you asked me. I just don't want you to mess this up.
所以，我对您即将在小石城建立的总统图书馆感到兴奋。我再也不用负责向朋友、家人和偶尔搭乘的出租车司机捍卫您的名誉了。能把我对您剩余的信任转交给阿肯色州的一座建筑，真是如释重负。但在我卸下您那尖酸刻薄的小啦啦队长的职务之前，我考察了四个总统图书馆，以帮您弄清楚如何做好这份工作。并不是您要求我这么做的，我只是不想让您搞砸。
We'll begin our tour at the John F. Kennedy Library overlooking Boston Harbor, partly because your youth and flash have been described as Kennedy-esque and partly because you, yourself, have often invoked the comparison, most notably by trotting out that film of you shaking JFK's hand as a teenager, an image of eerie destiny. I talked to the Kennedy Library's curator, Frank Rigg. We agreed that the plainest pleasure of visiting presidential libraries is getting close to the actual stuff of history.
我们的行程从俯瞰波士顿港的约翰·F·肯尼迪图书馆开始，部分原因是因为您的青春和风采曾被描述为“肯尼迪式”，部分原因是您自己也经常引用这种对比，最著名的就是展示那段您少年时期与肯尼迪握手的影像，那真是一种不可思议的宿命画面。我采访了肯尼迪图书馆的馆长弗兰克·里格。我们一致认为，参观总统图书馆最纯粹的乐趣就是近距离接触真实的历史遗迹。
We have on display in one of the cases in that room the little card in which he's written, "Ich bin ein Berliner," spelled out phonetically so he would-- and if you watch the film, you can see just before he gets to that line, he looks down at the paper and then looks up and says, "Ich bin ein Berliner." And I love those little correspondences between an artifact and a piece of film.
我们在那个房间的一个展示柜里陈列着他写的小卡片，上面用拼音拼写着“我是一个柏林人”，这样他就能……如果你看那部电影，你可以看到他在说出那句台词之前，向下看了一眼纸条，然后抬起头说：“我是一个柏林人。”我喜欢这些文物与电影片段之间的微小对应。
And the most beautiful one comes towards the end of the museum where we have a video of his tour of Ireland in 1963. And as he was leaving, he quoted a piece of poetry that Mrs. de Valera, the wife of the president of Ireland, had recited to him the night before at dinner. And he'd written them down on the back of his itinerary.
最美的一处出现在博物馆结尾，那里有他1963年访问爱尔兰的录像。当他离开时，他引用了爱尔兰总统夫人德瓦莱拉夫人在前一天晚宴上对他诵读的一首诗。他把诗句写在了行程单的背面。
And she immediately quoted this poem. And I wrote down the words because I thought they're beautiful.
她立即诵读了这首诗。我记下了这些词，因为我觉得它们很美。
And you see him in the film pick up a piece of paper that he has under a silver jug. It's windy, that's why he has it under the-- and it's blowing around in the wind. And he picks it up, and then he recites. There's these very beautiful lines.
在影片中，你可以看到他拿起一张放在银壶下面的纸。当时风很大，这就是为什么他把它压在……它在风中飘来飘去。他把它捡起来，然后朗诵。这些诗句非常美。
Thus returns from travels long, years of exile, years of pain, to see old Shannon's face again, over the waters glancing. Well, I'm going to come back and see old Shannon's face again.
从漫长的旅途中归来，告别岁月的流亡与痛苦，再次见到香农河面上的倒影，水波荡漾。嗯，我要回来再看一眼香农河的容颜。
At the end of the recitation, he folds it up. And you can see the crease. And again, it's one of those things where you feel as if you're there at that moment in time.
朗诵结束时，他把它叠了起来。你可以看到折痕。再说一次，这就是那种让你感觉仿佛置身于那个时刻的东西。
In this I.M. Pei-designed white box, JFK's life and death unfold primarily on television monitors and video screens. I walk in suspicious. I've never particularly worshipped Jack Kennedy. He didn't really do anything except talk. He spoke of civil rights, but it was Lyndon Johnson who got actual laws passed. And then there's the minor matter of the Cuban Missile Crisis, perhaps the scariest single week in the history of the world. And yet, at JFK's Library, I found myself hoodwinked by pretty words.
在这座由贝聿铭设计的白色方盒里，肯尼迪的生与死主要通过电视监视器和视频屏幕展现。我带着怀疑走进去。我从未特别崇拜杰克·肯尼迪。他除了谈论，并没有真正做过什么。他谈论民权，但真正通过法律的是林登·约翰逊。还有古巴导弹危机这个小问题，那可能是世界历史上最可怕的一周。然而，在肯尼迪图书馆，我发现自己被华丽的辞藻欺骗了。
No other free nation has demanded so much of itself. Through hot wars and cold, through recession and prosperity, through the ages of the atom and outer space, the American people have neither faltered, nor has their faith flagged. If at times our actions seem to make life difficult for others, it is only because history has made life difficult for us all.
没有其他自由国家对自己要求如此严苛。经历过热战与冷战，经历过衰退与繁荣，经历过原子能和外太空时代，美国人民从未动摇，信念也从未减弱。如果有时我们的行为似乎让别人的生活变得困难，那仅仅是因为历史让所有人的生活都变得艰难。
As you may have noticed, there are no narrators to our films and our videos. The principle voice is that of John F. Kennedy himself. And we did that very consciously.
正如您可能注意到的，我们的电影和视频没有旁白。主要的声音就是约翰·F·肯尼迪本人。我们是有意识这样做的。
There are also a lot of pretty pictures-- home movies of JFK handing a dandelion to John-John, one weirdly evocative film strip of the president in which all he does is carry a briefcase and walk to a car. I watch this wondering, why is it so riveting? He's taking work home. But I can't resist him. The man is Medusa. Don't look in his eyes.
这里还有很多漂亮的图片——肯尼迪把蒲公英递给小约翰的家庭录像，还有一段奇怪但引人入胜的总统胶片，他只是提着公文包走向汽车。看着这个，我心想，为什么它如此引人入胜？他只是把工作带回家而已。但我无法抗拒他。这个男人是美杜莎。不要看他的眼睛。
President Clinton, you should milk this in your library. Where the legislative record is perhaps ambiguous or downright shabby, go for the flashy soundbites. You're such a sweet talker, the Charlie Parker of the press conference Q&A, riffing rhythmically about everything from interest rates to Greece versus Turkey with regards to Cyprus. Get a couple of great quotes, throw a little music under them, and listen to what a great president you were.
克林顿总统，您在图书馆里应该利用这一点。当立法记录可能模棱两可甚至糟糕透顶时，就去用那些华丽的音效和片段。您是如此健谈，简直是新闻发布会问答环节的查理·帕克，从利率到塞浦路斯问题上的希腊与土耳其之争，随性而有节奏地即兴发挥。选几个精彩的引语，配上一段音乐，听听您是一位多么伟大的总统。
America is far more than a place. It is an idea, the most powerful idea in the history of nations. And all of us in this chamber, we are now the bearers of that idea.
美国不仅仅是一个地方。它是一个理念，民族史上最强大的理念。而在座的各位，我们现在都是这一理念的承载者。
When we get this all worked out, we're all living to be 150, young people will still fall in love. Old people will still fight about things that should have been resolved 50 years ago. We will all on occasion do stupid things. And we will all see the unbelievable capacity of humanity to be noble. This is a great day.
当我们解决了一切问题，大家都活到150岁时，年轻人依然会坠入爱河。老年人依然会因为50年前就该解决的事情而争吵。我们偶尔都会做蠢事。我们都会看到人性中高尚的那种难以置信的能力。这是伟大的一天。
General Dwight D. Eisenhower, a military meteor on the rise.
德怀特·D·艾森豪威尔将军，一颗冉冉升起的军事流星。
President Clinton, I wanted to go to the Dwight David Eisenhower Library in Abilene, Kansas, to see how they handle something your library will have to tackle. Which is, if one of the achievements of a presidency is economic prosperity, how do you display that without putting out a bunch of toasters and hula hoops, without making people seem dumb and materialistic? How do you convey the decency of making people's lives better?
克林顿总统，我想去堪萨斯州阿比林的德怀特·戴维·艾森豪威尔图书馆，看看他们是如何处理您的图书馆必须面对的问题。那就是，如果总统任期的成就之一是经济繁荣，该如何展示它，而不至于摆出一堆烤面包机和呼啦圈，不让人们看起来愚蠢而物质化？您如何传达让人们生活得更好的那种体面？
Unfortunately for our project, the way the Eisenhower Library deals with this challenge is they basically ignore it. In fact, you'd barely know the man was president. The exhibit devoted to his White House years is mostly heaps of weird, but swanky gifts he got, like a mosaic desk from the Shah of Iran. What the museum's great at is Eisenhower's military career. As I walk around with its director, Dan Holt, I think, who cares if he accomplished anything after V-J Day?
不幸的是，对于我们的项目来说，艾森豪威尔图书馆处理这一挑战的方式基本上就是无视它。事实上，您几乎看不出这个人当过总统。专门展示他在白宫岁月的部分主要是他收到的一堆奇怪但时髦的礼物，比如伊朗国王送的马赛克书桌。该博物馆擅长的是艾森豪威尔的军事生涯。当我和馆长丹·霍尔特走在一起时，我想，谁会在乎他在VJ日之后完成了什么？
And this is some early World War II-- the original note that Roosevelt and Churchill signed appointing Eisenhower the Supreme Commander.
这是早期二战的一些原件——罗斯福和丘吉尔签署的任命艾森豪威尔为盟军最高统帅的原始便条。
It's funny, at this point in the museum, I forgot he was president.
很有趣，在博物馆的这个阶段，我忘记了他曾经是总统。
Yeah, right. Yeah.
是的，没错。是的。
President Clinton, there is a lesson to be learned here after all. Which is, play to your strength. Eisenhower's greatest achievement was liberating Europe. Your greatest achievement? Balancing the budget. Not as dramatic, I know. They're probably not going to make a Tom Hanks movie about fiscal policy, no matter how inspired that fiscal policy might be.
克林顿总统，归根结底这里有一个教训。那就是，发挥您的优势。艾森豪威尔最大的成就是解放欧洲。您最大的成就呢？平衡预算。我知道，这没那么有戏剧性。不管财政政策有多出色，他们大概不会拍一部关于财政政策的汤姆·汉克斯电影。
But still, as the White House web page cheerfully points out, your money wrangling did create the longest economic expansion in US history and the most new jobs ever created in a single administration. In the Eisenhower Library, the climax of the visit is D-Day in which you turn a sharp corner, and suddenly, you're standing like a soldier on a ship's ramp facing a Normandy beach.
但即便如此，正如白宫网页兴高采烈指出的那样，您的金钱博弈确实创造了美国历史上最长的经济扩张和单届政府创造就业最多的纪录。在艾森豪威尔图书馆，参观的高潮是诺曼底登陆，你转过一个急转弯，突然间，你就站在像士兵一样的船坡道上，面对着诺曼底海滩。
And then you walk through a small mock-up of an LCI, Landing Craft Infantry, and then the photograph that's been called The Jaws of Death, which is the landings on Omaha Beach.
然后你穿过一个小型LCI（步兵登陆艇）模型，接着是被称为“死亡之口”的照片，即奥马哈海滩的登陆场景。
As you trudge across the ramp, you glimpse your buddies ahead of you slogging through the bloody wet, and the beach so far away. In short, this is very effective theater, which leads me to my next recommendation, Mr. Clinton. What about a similar stage set? Only in your library, instead of being a soldier leaving the boat for Omaha Beach, the visitor could walk in the shoes of Fed chairman Alan Greenspan as he steps out of a Lincoln Town Car and into the Dirksen Senate Office Building to endorse the Clinton deficit-reduction strategy before the Senate Banking Committee.
当你艰难地走过坡道时，你瞥见前方你的伙伴们在血腥的湿地里跋涉，海滩离得那么远。简而言之，这是非常有效的剧场，这引出了我的下一个建议，克林顿先生。为什么不设置一个类似的场景？只是在您的图书馆里，参观者不再是离开船前往奥马哈海滩的士兵，而是可以代入美联储主席艾伦·格林斯潘的角色，体验他走下林肯轿车，走进迪克森参议院办公大楼，在参议院银行委员会面前支持克林顿赤字削减战略的过程。
A word on the people who run these libraries, Mr. President. Fortunately for you guys, they are very attached to their subjects, very loyal. Their president becomes a kind of mental roommate, someone they live with. And each of the library directors I interviewed spoke of their president with affection, like moms almost. Dan Holt praises Ike's correspondence skill.
关于管理这些图书馆的人，总统先生。对你们来说幸运的是，他们对自己所服务的对象非常投入，非常忠诚。他们的总统变成了一种心理室友，一个他们与之共同生活的人。我采访的每一位图书馆馆长都带着感情谈论他们的总统，简直像妈妈一样。丹·霍尔特称赞艾克的通信技巧。
Eisenhower was a wonderful letter writer.
艾森豪威尔是一位出色的书信作者。
Talks up up his private sector prowess.
谈论他在私营部门的精明。
He was an outstanding business man.
他是一位杰出的商人。
His book learning.
他的读书水平。
His grammar is very good. As a matter of fact, when you read his diaries and letters, even the diaries, you can hardly ever find a misspelled word.
他的语法非常好。事实上，当你读他的日记和信件，甚至是日记时，你几乎找不到拼写错误的词。
And his looks.
还有他的外表。
Oh, he was a very handsome man.
哦，他是一个非常英俊的男人。
All the loyalty you would want while you're in office you finally get after you quit. None of the library directors have written kiss-and-tell memoirs and gone on to work for ABC.
所有您在任期内想要的忠诚，您最终在离任后得到了。没有一位图书馆馆长写过这种“爆料式”回忆录并跳槽到ABC新闻工作。
If you were involved in the planning for this new presidential library in Little Rock, is there any advice you could give to those people based on your experience?
如果您参与了小石城这座新总统图书馆的规划，基于您的经验，您能给那些人什么建议吗？
Bigger restrooms and more drinking fountains. But I think you have to have fun in it. I'm a true believer of that, that there has to be bells and whistles.
更大的洗手间和更多的饮水机。但我认为你必须在里面玩得开心。我是这一点的忠实拥护者，必须要有各种吸引人的花哨玩意儿。
The first thing I think we'll take a look at is called an animatron. It is a figure of LBJ. It has sound with it. And it tells some of Johnson's stories.
我们要看的第一个东西叫“电子动画人物”。这是一个林登·约翰逊的塑像。它有声音，讲述了一些约翰逊的故事。
I'm with library director Harry Middleton in the Lyndon Baines Johnson Library and Museum in Austin, Texas. We're looking at a robot of LBJ, a robot who wears cowboy garb and tells folksy stories. Have you heard the one about the man who goes to a doctor because he's hard of hearing? The doctor advises the man to quit drinking and sends him home. A few days later, the man returns to the doctor's office. He hasn't stopped his drinking. The doctor scolds him.
我正和馆长哈里·米德尔顿在德克萨斯州奥斯汀的林登·贝恩斯·约翰逊图书馆和博物馆。我们正在看一个LBJ机器人，一个穿着牛仔装、讲着乡土故事的机器人。你听过那个男人因为听力不好去看医生的故事吗？医生建议那个人戒酒，并让他回家。几天后，那个人回到诊所。他并没有戒酒。医生责备他。
He said, didn't I tell you when you were here that you should cut out your drinking if you wanted to improve your hearing? He said, yes. Well, he said, why didn't you do it? Well, he said, doctor, he said, I got home, and I considered it. And I just decided that I like what I drinks much better than what I heard.
他说，我上次不是跟你说过了吗，如果你想改善听力，就得戒酒？他说，是的。嗯，他说，那你为什么不戒？嗯，他说，医生，我回家考虑了一下。我决定我喜欢喝酒比喜欢听到的声音要多得多。
And as we move into this area, we show some of the correspondence that President Johnson got, some of it quite critical, some of it supportive.
当我们进入这个区域时，我们展示了约翰逊总统收到的一些信件，有些相当尖锐，有些则表示支持。
There's a letter on the wall addressed to Lyndon Johnson from one Francis Mercer of Beverly Hills, California. "Mr. President, you have engaged this country in an active war without the consent of Congress. I consider having worked for your campaign one of the most tragic mistakes of my life."
墙上有封给林登·约翰逊的信，来自加州比佛利山的弗朗西斯·默瑟。“总统先生，您在未经国会同意的情况下让这个国家卷入了战争。我将为您的竞选工作视为我一生中最悲剧的错误之一。”
President Clinton, I'm going to hazard a guess that you, yourself, have received one or two angry letters. Which brings us to the question what are you going to do about all the people who hate your guts? Not to put too fine a point on it. What are you going to do about all the aspects of your presidency you'd rather forget about?
克林顿总统，我敢猜您自己也收到过一两封愤怒的信。这就引出了一个问题：您打算如何处理那些恨之入骨的人？说得直白一点。您打算如何处理那些您宁愿忘记的任期细节？
Tell me if this rumor is true that, in the initial exhibitions, there was little or no representation of Vietnam, and that the President himself came to the library and insisted that that part of the exhibition be beefed up.
告诉我这个传言是否属实：在最初的展览中，关于越南的内容很少或根本没有，而总统本人来到图书馆，坚持要求充实那部分展览。
To a certain extent, that's true. There was a representation of Vietnam, but nothing that showed the controversy of Vietnam. And when President Johnson walked through the library just a few weeks before the library was to open, one of the things that he commented on was that the library did not indicate how contentious that time was. And he said to me, that was a very controversial period, and we've got to make sure that people know that we understand that. And he said to me, I don't want another damn credibility gap.
在某种程度上这是真的。确实有关于越南的展示，但没有展示越南战争的争议性。当约翰逊总统在图书馆开放前几周参观时，他评论的一点是，图书馆没有体现出那个时代的争议性。他对我说，那是一个非常有争议的时期，我们必须确保人们知道我们理解这一点。他对我说，我不想要另一个该死的信任危机。
And do you think the people who are in charge of a president's legacy are more apt to protect him than the president himself would be of his own legacy?
您认为负责总统遗产的人是否比总统本人更倾向于保护他？
Yeah, I think that's probably true. I think unless you get a clear direction from the president that he wants it all laid out-- in the case of Johnson, I've been director here from the beginning. And on one occasion when he was concerned that we might be too protective, he said to me, good men have been trying to protect my reputation for 40 years, and not a damn one has succeeded. Now what makes you think you can? So we've not tried to do that since.
是的，我认为这很可能是真的。我认为除非总统明确指示他想把一切都展示出来——就约翰逊而言，我从一开始就是这里的馆长。有一次，当他担心我们可能保护过度时，他说，好人已经努力保护了我的名誉40年，没有一个成功的。现在你凭什么认为你能？所以从那以后，我们就不再尝试那么做了。
Mr. Clinton, here's a list of things you should not whitewash. Before we even discuss the scandals, let's talk about the ordinary failures. What about one of your key campaign promises, to reform health care? A fiasco. Ditto Waco. Or the 1994 Congressional elections in which the voting public punched Republican names on their ballots with one hand while using their other hands to give you the finger.
克林顿先生，这里有一份您不应该粉饰的事情清单。在我们讨论丑闻之前，先谈谈那些普通的失败。您竞选时的核心承诺之一——医疗改革怎么样？一场惨败。韦科惨案也一样。还有1994年的国会选举，投票民众一只手在选票上打勾共和党人，另一只手给您竖中指。
I'm not even mentioning all the half-assed policies, like Don't Ask, Don't Tell, or Bosnia, or Somalia. Finally, you did have sexual relations with that woman. You have to confront this. Again, LBJ Library director Harry Middleton.
我还没提所有那些半吊子政策，比如“不问不说”、波斯尼亚或索马里。最后，您确实与那个女人发生了性关系。您必须面对这一点。再次引用LBJ图书馆馆长哈里·米德尔顿的话。
I think that a library should not proselytize and should not sugarcoat, and should not in any way distort the facts or the truth in order to hide a controversy surrounding the president. Otherwise, it's just unfair to the public.
我认为图书馆不应该传教，不应该粉饰，不应该以任何方式歪曲事实或真相来隐藏围绕总统的争议。否则，这对公众是不公平的。
Meanwhile, in Yorba Linda, California.
与此同时，在加州约巴琳达。
Well, first of all, I don't think a presidential library should necessarily bend over backwards to be objective and fair and inclusive of every important and telling fact on all sides of the argument.
好吧，首先，我不认为总统图书馆必须竭尽全力去追求客观、公平，并包罗所有争论双方的重要事实。
This is John Taylor, director of the Richard Nixon Library and Birthplace. It's about a 15-minute drive from Disneyland. Just as Harry Middleton of the LBJ Library is doing his job according to LBJ's wishes, John Taylor is doing his job the way Nixon would want.
这是约翰·泰勒，理查德·尼克松图书馆和故居的馆长。距离迪士尼乐园大约15分钟车程。正如LBJ图书馆的哈里·米德尔顿按照约翰逊的意愿工作一样，约翰·泰勒也按照尼克松想要的风格工作。
I think people expect presidential libraries to reflect the point of view of the president, the president's family, and the president's institutional advocates.
我认为人们期望总统图书馆反映总统、总统家人以及总统制度捍卫者的观点。
I'm ambling through the museum, past pictures of Nixon, all smiles in China. And one of the other visitors asks the guard, "Where's Watergate?" The guard tells him, "Keep going straight. It's a dark room." And it is, a very dimly lit tunnel chronicling the break-in at the Watergate Hotel through President Nixon's resignation and farewell.
我在博物馆里漫步，走过尼克松在中国满脸笑容的照片。其中一位参观者问保安，“水门事件在哪？”保安告诉他，“一直往前走。那是个黑暗的房间。”确实如此，那是一条灯光昏暗的隧道，记录了从水门酒店入室盗窃到尼克松总统辞职告别的全过程。
There are stations in the Watergate Gallery where one may listen to the famous tapes. And there are intricate text panels with labels like, "What did the president do, and when did he do it?" John Taylor says that one of the purposes of this exhibit is that people come here expecting the museum to avoid such a sore subject. And that dealing with it in such an info-packed manner gives them credibility.
水门事件展厅里有可以收听著名录音带的装置。还有复杂的文字说明版，标题如“总统做了什么，他什么时候做的？”约翰·泰勒说，这个展览的目的之一是，人们来这里时预期博物馆会回避这样一个伤疤，而以如此信息量大的方式处理它，赋予了他们可信度。
But the most important reason to tell the story is that it happened. It was an amazing outbreak of political passion. The anger that Congress expressed during the Senate investigation in 1973 and the impeachment investigation in 1974 was passion that had been building probably since the events around the time of Kent State.
但讲述这个故事最重要的原因是它确实发生了。那是一场令人惊叹的政治激情爆发。国会在1973年参议院调查和1974年弹劾调查期间表达的愤怒，是自肯特州立大学事件前后就开始积聚的激情。
And I think one sees the same effect with President Clinton who was also a figure about whom there was simmering passions among many conservatives. There was a strong feeling among many conservatives, as we all know, that he quote "was not legitimate" close quote or that he had been engaged in activities which had never been fully revealed to the American people. And many of those passions came forth during the impeachment investigation and proceedings in 1998 and 1999.
我认为在克林顿总统身上也能看到同样的效果，他也是一个在保守派中引发强烈激情的人物。正如我们所知，许多保守派人士强烈认为他引用“是不合法的”引号，或者他参与了从未完全向美国人民揭露的活动。这些激情中有许多在1998年和1999年的弹劾调查和程序中爆发出来。
Taylor offers this advice to you and your library director, President Clinton.
泰勒为克林顿总统和您的图书馆馆长提供了这个建议。
I think it would be appropriate for the Clinton Library to try to make the case, for instance, that there was a political dimension to the Clinton impeachment. And there were people, who did not think President and Mrs. Clinton should be in the White House, who used the impeachment effort as a way to accomplish that end. Pointing that out is fair comment. We pointed out in our museum, and I would think and assume that they would attempt to do so in Little Rock as well.
我认为克林顿图书馆尝试去证明例如弹劾具有政治维度是合适的。确实有些人认为总统和夫人不应该留在白宫，他们利用弹劾行动作为实现这一目的的手段。指出这一点是公平的评价。我们在博物馆里指出了这一点，我想并假设他们在小石城也会尝试这样做。
There's a lot you can crib from the Nixon Library, Mr. President. Just substitute the name Clinton for the name Nixon in the following text from the Watergate exhibit. It reads, "Nixon himself said he made inexcusable misjudgments. But what is equally clear is that his opponents ruthlessly exploited those misjudgments as a way to further their own purely political goals."
总统先生，您可以从尼克松图书馆借鉴很多东西。只需在水门事件展览的下列文字中把“尼克松”这个名字换成“克林顿”。它写道：“尼克松本人说他犯了不可原谅的判断错误。但同样清楚的是，他的对手无情地利用了这些错误，作为推进他们纯粹政治目标的手段。”
One caution, Mr. President. The Nixon Library can sometimes seem a little defensive. In the LBJ Library, a visitor's view of history is complicated by presenting both sides of the Vietnam dilemma. It's an emotional place, but still operates within the language of good old-fashioned civics, a president and his constituents loudly agreeing to disagree. The Nixon Library asks, you want facts? We'll give you some facts. And oh, by the way, grow up. Because you're not going to like any of them.
一个提醒，总统先生。尼克松图书馆有时会显得有点防卫过当。在LBJ图书馆，游客的历史观因呈现了越南困境的双方观点而变得复杂。这是一个情感丰富的地方，但仍然在传统的公民学语言框架内运作，总统与其选民大声地同意持有不同意见。尼克松图书馆问的是，你想要事实？我们会给你一些事实。顺便说一句，成熟点吧。因为你不会喜欢其中的任何一个。
In May of this year, we marked the anniversary of the death of four students at Kent State. Thanks to the Neil Young song, thanks to the way that event is generally packaged in the media and in history, one rarely hears about it from the perspective of Richard Nixon.
今年五月，我们纪念了肯特州立大学四名学生遇难周年。感谢尼尔·杨的那首歌，感谢媒体和历史通常包装该事件的方式，人们很少从理查德·尼克松的角度听到它的声音。
But when you hear President Nixon talking in our presidential forum about what a dark day that was for him, it challenges the prevailing thought that he was callous and unfeeling toward the families of those who had died. In fact, he says in this museum and says in his memoirs that it was the darkest day of his presidency. And he includes Watergate when he makes that calculation.
但当你听到尼克松总统在我们的总统论坛上谈论那是他多么黑暗的一天时，它挑战了那种认为他对待死者家属冷酷无情的流行看法。事实上，他在这个博物馆和回忆录中都说，这是他总统任期内最黑暗的一天。他在做这个计算时包括了水门事件。
At the same time, however, you also learn, when going through the museum, that President Nixon had to weigh the lives of those four innocent young people against the lives of innumerable south Vietnamese and American soldiers whose lives were saved as a result of the incursion into Cambodia which was the proximate cause of the demonstration at Kent State which got out of hand and led to the deaths.
与此同时，在参观博物馆时，你也会了解到，尼克松总统必须权衡那四名无辜年轻人的生命与无数南越和美国士兵的生命，后者的生命因入侵柬埔寨而得救，而那正是肯特州立大学示威活动的直接诱因，最终导致了失控和死亡。
President Clinton, perhaps you're wondering if the Nixon Library changed my mind about anything. You're wondering if citizens who shook their fists at your face on TV might someday drop in on a building with your name on it and maybe give you a break. All I can tell you is that I still think Watergate's a horror and Vietnam was wrong. But I do find it useful to remember that those decisions, even the most deadly ones, were made not by a supernatural monster, but by a real man whom we elected, a man who at least believed he was right. And that is not nothing.
克林顿总统，也许您在想尼克松图书馆是否改变了我对任何事情的看法。您在想那些曾在电视上对您挥拳的公民，是否有一天会走进一座写着您名字的建筑，也许会放您一马。我能说的就是，我仍然认为水门事件是个可怕的事，越南战争是错误的。但我确实发现记住这些决定——即使是最致命的决定——不是由超自然怪物，而是由我们选举出来的真实人类做出的，一个至少相信自己正确的人，这一点很有用。这并非毫无意义。
In fact, the Nixon and Johnson Libraries were my favorite ones to visit because they deal with quarrelsome subjects. Once, years ago, I was at the LBJ Library. I was walking away from a copy of the Voting Rights Act of 1965 towards a photo of a serviceman who'd been killed in Vietnam. In the 10 seconds it took to walk from that law to that face, a song from a nearby pop music exhibit started playing, "Louie Louie." And I felt like all of America was in that 10 seconds. The grandeur of civil rights, the consequences of war, and the fun, fun, fun of a truly strange song.
事实上，尼克松和约翰逊图书馆是我最喜欢参观的，因为它们处理了充满争议的主题。多年前，我曾在LBJ图书馆。我从一份1965年《投票权法案》的副本走开，走向一张在越南阵亡士兵的照片。在那从法律走向那张脸的10秒钟里，附近一个流行音乐展览开始播放一首歌，《路易路易》。我觉得整个美国都浓缩在那10秒钟里了。民权的宏大、战争的代价，以及一首真正奇怪的歌带来的乐趣、乐趣和乐趣。
Mr. President, Americans like contradictions. We elected you, didn't we? So in your library, own up to your failures, but don't stop trying to win us over. In other words, just think of it as running for president forever.
总统先生，美国人喜欢矛盾。我们选了您，不是吗？所以在您的图书馆里，承认您的失败，但不要停止试图赢取我们。换句话说，把它当作一场永无止境的总统竞选。
Sarah Vowell's latest book is called Take the Cannoli.
莎拉·沃威尔的最新书名为《带上坎诺利》。
Coming up, Lee Harvey Oswald's Little League career and other things his mother would like you to know before you judge him too harshly in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德的少棒生涯以及他母亲希望您在评判他之前了解的其他事情，公共广播国际在节目继续后为您播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Memo To The People Of The Future, stories of people who want to control how history will see them. We've arrived at Act Two, an act we've called One And One Don't Make Two. What if you're remembered the wrong way? What if you're remembered for something that somebody else did? Well, consider the case of Marguerite Oswald, Lee Harvey Oswald's mother.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是：致未来之人的备忘录，讲述了那些想要控制历史将如何看待他们的人的故事。我们到了第二章，我们称之为“一加一不等于二”。如果你被人们以错误的方式记住怎么办？如果你因为别人做的事情而被记住怎么办？那么，考虑一下李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德的母亲玛格丽特·奥斯瓦尔德的案例。
In 1965, a reporter named Jean Stafford spent three days with Mrs. Oswald at Oswald's home in Fort Worth, Texas, to write a story for McCall's Magazine. Later, she expanded this story into a book called A Mother in History. The book's out of print now. Jean Stafford died about 20 years ago. And the tapes of these interviews were archived with the rest of Stafford's papers at the University of Colorado at Boulder. According to the librarians in the Special Collections department there, this is the first time these tapes have ever been heard by anyone other than Jean Stafford and Mrs. Oswald herself. This American Life producer Susan Burton tracked down the tapes and listened to them.
1965年，一位名叫吉恩·斯塔福德的记者在德克萨斯州沃斯堡的奥斯瓦尔德家中与奥斯瓦尔德夫人共度了三天，为《麦考尔杂志》撰写报道。后来，她将这个故事扩展成了一本名为《历史中的母亲》的书。这本书现在已经绝版。吉恩·斯塔福德大约20年前去世。这些采访的磁带与斯塔福德其余的文件一起存放在科罗拉多大学博尔德分校。据那里的特别收藏部馆员称，这是除了吉恩·斯塔福德和奥斯瓦尔德夫人本人外，这些录音第一次被任何人听到。《美国生活》制作人苏珊·伯顿找到了这些录音并进行了收听。
On the afternoon Jean Stafford first came to visit Mrs. Oswald in her white stucco bungalow, the two sat in the living room drinking coffee. A print of Whistler's famous portrait of his mother hung over the couch. Stafford thought she would start out by asking Mrs. Oswald about something small and personal, like her recipe for brownies. "But before I could open my mouth," she wrote later, "Mrs. Oswald opened hers and never shut it once during the three monologues she granted me."
吉恩·斯塔福德第一次去拜访奥斯瓦尔德夫人那座白色灰泥平房的那个下午，两人坐在客厅里喝咖啡。惠斯勒那幅著名的母亲肖像画印件挂在沙发上方。斯塔福德本想从询问奥斯瓦尔德夫人一些琐碎私人的事情开始，比如她的布朗尼配方。“但在我张嘴之前，”她后来写道，“奥斯瓦尔德夫人就开了口，并在她答应给我的三次独白中一次也没有停下来。”
It turned out that Mrs. Oswald thought that she and her son were being remembered the wrong way. And she'd devoted her life to setting the record straight. On these scratchy tapes, she tells stories like this one about when Lee was in seventh grade, and the two of them had just moved to New York.
事实证明，奥斯瓦尔德夫人认为她和儿子被人们以错误的方式记住了。她毕生致力于纠正记录。在这些沙沙作响的录音带上，她讲述了类似李上七年级时，两人刚搬到纽约的故事。
Lee came home one day. And we were in New  York just about a week or so. And it was exactly the time he was supposed to get home from school. He said, "Mother, I didn't go to school today." I said, "You didn't? Where did you go?" "Oh," he said, "I rode all around." He said, "I rode all day long on the subway. I went to Brooklyn. I went to Queens, blah, blah, blah." Now I want to say this. How many boys at age 13 that play hooky from school would come home and tell his mother that he did so? And he did. In defense of my son, let's have some defense of Lee Harvey Oswald and his mother.
李有一天回家。我们刚到纽约大约一周左右。这正是他应该从学校回家的确切时间。他说：“妈妈，我今天没去学校。”我说：“你没去？你去哪了？”“哦，”他说，“我到处转了转。”他说，“我整天都在坐地铁。我去了布鲁克林，去了皇后区，等等，等等。”现在我想说的是。有多少13岁的男孩逃学后会回家告诉母亲他这么做了？但他说了。为了维护我的儿子，让我们为李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德和他的母亲辩护一下吧。
The Warren Commission's 26-volume investigation into the Kennedy assassination discusses Lee's childhood at length. The Commission collected testimony about everything from his favorite board games to his fondness for playing hooky. They described how Mrs. Oswald sent Lee and his brothers to an orphanage then took them out again, how she moved the family around a lot, how this led Lee to become the kind of anti-social loner who'd shoot a president.
沃伦委员会关于肯尼迪遇刺案的26卷调查详细讨论了李的童年。委员会收集了关于他从最喜欢的棋盘游戏到喜欢逃学的一切证词。他们描述了奥斯瓦尔德夫人如何把李和他的兄弟送到孤儿院然后又接了出来，她如何频繁搬家，这如何导致李成为了那种会枪杀总统的反社会孤独者。
From Mrs. Oswald's point of view, the government basically gave a grant to people who wanted to prove what a bad mother she was. Plus, she complained to Jean Stafford, they didn't have the courtesy to come to me and verify these facts. They printed whatever they were told. Take, for instance, the testimony her sister gave about a trip Lee took to New Orleans back when he was 11 years old.
在奥斯瓦尔德夫人的观点里，政府基本上给那些想证明她是个糟糕母亲的人提供了拨款。此外，她向吉恩·斯塔福德抱怨，他们没有礼貌来找她核实这些事实。他们把被告知的一切都打印了出来。以她妹妹关于李在11岁时去新奥尔良的旅行提供的证词为例。
My sister remarks in her testimony that while he was there, he refused to play with any other children. She went into great details that they tried to get him out of the house and play with the children. Let's understand things a little bit. Here was a perfect stranger, a visitor. I have to smile because the whole thing is so ridiculous. Did she bring any 11-year or 12-year-olds into the home for Lee to meet? And did he refuse to meet them and to go off and play with them? Ah, that would be different. But no, no. So again, let's have defense of Lee Harvey Oswald.
我妹妹在证词中提到，他在那里时拒绝与任何其他孩子一起玩。她详细描述了他们如何试图让他出门与孩子们一起玩。让我们理清一下事情。这可是一个完全的陌生人，一个访客。我不得不笑，因为整件事太荒谬了。她把任何11或12岁的孩子带到家里让李见了吗？而他拒绝见他们并和他们一起去玩？啊，那又是另一回事了。但没有，没有。所以再一次，让我们为李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德辩护。
Why am I so concerned that the people will understand? It is natural because, as I say, I am in 26 volumes of the president's report, which is all over the world. And so I must defend myself and defend my son Lee.
为什么我如此担心人们能理解？这是自然的，因为正如我所说，我身处总统报告的26卷里，这些报告遍布世界各地。所以我必须捍卫自己，捍卫我的儿子李。
Did Lee like sports?
李喜欢运动吗？
Yes, he loved sports. He played baseball. I know, when I was in the insurance business, I took him to Farrington Field right here in Fort Worth, Texas, and watched him play. He used to play on a team. He belonged to the Y in Fort Worth, Texas. When I think of all the things that this boy did, how  can you call him a loner, or an introvert, or whatever they want to call him?
是的，他热爱运动。他打棒球。我知道，当我在保险业工作时，我带他去德克萨斯州沃斯堡的法林顿球场，看着他打球。他曾经在一个球队打球。他属于德克萨斯州沃斯堡的基督教青年会。当我想到这个男孩做的所有事情时，你怎么能叫他孤独者、内向者，或者任何他们想叫的名字？
Well, he was going to be 20 in October. And that's when he hit Russia, which brings another point. All of the news media, he's such a failure in life, even The Warren Commission, such a failure in life. A failure in life at 19 and 20, a young boy going to Russia? I think this took courage, for whatever reason he went.
嗯，他十月份就要满20岁了。那就是他去俄罗斯的时候，这引出了另一点。所有的新闻媒体，他生命中的失败者，甚至沃伦委员会，生命中的失败者。在19岁和20岁时就是生命中的失败者，一个年轻人去俄罗斯？我想这需要勇气，无论他出于什么原因去那里。
Most boys are going to college. These men don't understand. These men that are making $100 and $150 a day, the attorneys that are interviewing these witnesses and all. They never lived this type life. I find this a very intelligent boy, and I am really proud. I think he's coming out in history as a very fine boy.
大多数男孩都在上大学。这些人不明白。这些每天赚100美元和150美元的男人，那些采访证人的律师们，他们从来没过过这种生活。我发现这是一个非常聪明的男孩，我真的很骄傲。我认为他作为一个非常优秀的男孩被载入历史。
She was so convinced that he was coming out in history as a fine boy that she actually tried to get Lee buried in Arlington Cemetery. Even so, it's hard not to feel sympathetic toward her. The most innocuous things she did as a parent were being scrutinized by millions of people. And she didn't believe her son had killed the president.
她深信他作为一个优秀的男孩被载入历史，以至于她实际上试图把李安葬在阿灵顿公墓。即便如此，很难不对她产生同情。她作为父母做的最无伤大雅的事情都被数百万人审视。而且她不相信是她儿子杀害了总统。
Like 3/4 of all Americans today, she thought he'd been caught up in some bigger conspiracy. Though her ideas about that conspiracy included a few scenarios that The Warren Commission probably didn't bother to investigate. Like her theory that the owners of Neiman Marcus were behind the assassination. Or the one that Lee's Russian wife, Marina Nikolayevna Prusakova was French, not Russian. Or the one that Lee was under surveillance back at Arlington Heights High School.
像今天3/4的美国人一样，她认为他卷入了一些更大的阴谋。尽管她关于那个阴谋的想法包括了几个沃伦委员会可能懒得调查的情节。比如她认为内曼·马库斯百货的老板是暗杀幕后黑手的理论。或者李的俄罗斯妻子玛丽娜·尼古拉耶夫娜·普鲁萨科娃是法国人而不是俄罗斯人的理论。或者李在阿灵顿高地高中时受到监视的理论。
Lee, when we came back to Texas from New Orleans and he entered Arlington Heights High School, he entered in the end of September, I think is when school opens-- oh, let's give and take, the middle of September. And Lee joined the service on October the 17th. So approximately, he was in school four weeks. Yet, there are three pictures of my son for the yearbook. Now why pick out Lee Harvey Oswald?
李，当我们从新奥尔良回到德克萨斯，他进入阿灵顿高地高中时，他在9月底入学，我想那是学校开学的时候——哦，让我们取个大概，9月中旬。李在10月17日参军。所以大约，他在学校待了四周。然而，年鉴上有三张我儿子的照片。为什么单单挑出李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德？
Now you'll say, Mrs. Oswald, I don't get the point. Well, the point is it goes on, and on, and on, and on. This is an instance here, that Lee Harvey Oswald's picture was taken three times at Arlington Heights High School out of all the boys. You understand what I mean? And this goes on and on. It looks as though this boy's life has been supervised.
现在你会说，奥斯瓦尔德夫人，我不明白重点。嗯，重点是这没完没了。这是一个实例，李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德的照片在阿灵顿高地高中所有的男孩中被拍了三次。你明白我的意思吗？这没完没了。看起来这个男孩的生活一直受到监视。
There are some people who would like to think that I have hallucinations. I know. It's been already said in The Warren Commission Report. It was asked by some of the attorneys, point blank, words put in their mouth. Do you think your mother or do you think-- to my sister-- that your sister has hallucinations? Because why? Because I notice the inaccuracies and the coincidences and things that don't jive? Because I know some who wouldn't hesitate to try to make a mental case out of me. And believe me, if anybody's in their right mind, it's Mrs. Marguerite Oswald.
有些人愿意认为我有幻觉。我知道。沃伦委员会报告里已经这么说了。有些律师直接问，字里行间放入了他们的意思。你认为你母亲，或者你认为——对我妹妹说——你妹妹有幻觉吗？因为为什么？因为我注意到了那些不准确、巧合和不吻合的事情？因为我知道有些人不会犹豫尝试把我塑造成精神病例。相信我，如果有人神志清醒，那就是玛格丽特·奥斯瓦尔德夫人。
There's a way in which the kind of mother Mrs. Oswald most resembled was a stage mother. When Lee was in Russia, she traveled to Washington to personally petition President Kennedy to get him to come home. She spent most of each day managing her son's posthumous career, clipping articles, sending out photographs, phoning reporters, analyzing The Warren Report for character and motivation. But what happens when a stage mother becomes famous too?
奥斯瓦尔德夫人最像的那种母亲是那种舞台母亲。当李在俄罗斯时，她去华盛顿亲自请求肯尼迪总统让他回家。她每天大部分时间都在经营儿子的身后名声，剪报，寄照片，给记者打电话，分析沃伦报告中的性格和动机。但当一位舞台母亲也出名时会发生什么呢？
After the assassination, Mrs. Oswald toured the country, giving speeches about her son. She heard that Ernest Hemingway never gave away his autograph for free and started charging for hers too. She had a sense that she'd been picked to be in history, that she'd been cast in a great American epic. When there was news about Lee and she wasn't included, she was offended. For instance, when Lee's diary mysteriously appeared, she couldn't believe that the FBI didn't call to see if she'd been the one to release it.
暗杀发生后，奥斯瓦尔德夫人巡游全国，发表关于她儿子的演讲。她听说欧内斯特·海明威从来不免费给签名，于是开始对她的签名收费。她有一种感觉，她被选中进入历史，她被选中参与了一部伟大的美国史诗。当有关于李的新闻而没有包括她时，她会感到冒犯。例如，当李的日记神秘出现时，她无法相信联邦调查局没有打电话问是不是她发布的。
After the third day, I called the FBI, which is in Dallas. And I forget the man's name, and I told him who I was. And I said, I have been waiting for somebody to come over and question me about the release of the so-called diary. And I said, nobody has. And he said, well, do you have the diary, Mrs. Oswald? And I said, no, I don't. But I just can't imagine all the fuss about the diary and not coming and asking if I released the diary. He said, because they know you didn't have it.
第三天后，我打电话给达拉斯的联邦调查局。我忘了那个人的名字，我告诉他我是谁。我说，我一直在等有人过来审问我关于所谓日记发布的事情。我说，没有。他说，嗯，你有日记吗，奥斯瓦尔德夫人？我说，不，我没有。但我只是无法想象关于日记的所有大惊小怪，却没有来问是不是我发布的。他说，因为他们知道你没有。
But you see, now this is  a good example of agent or of whatever you want to say. Because, here, I could have had the diary if they were sincere. Let's face it. You see, one and one don't make two. My book's going to be One and One Don't Make Two or This and That. Those are the titles I'd like to have.
但你看，现在这是一个很好的经纪人例子，或者任何你想说的。因为，在这里，如果他们真诚的话，我本可以有那本日记的。让我们面对现实。你看，一加一不等于二。我的书就叫《一加一不等于二》或者《这个和那个》。这些是我想要的标题。
Mrs. Oswald honestly didn't understand why she didn't get the same kind of sympathy Mrs. Kennedy did. She felt a kind of kinship with her. In Mrs. Oswald's mind, they'd gone through something very similar.
奥斯瓦尔德夫人真诚地不明白为什么她没有得到像肯尼迪夫人那样的同情。她感到与她有一种亲缘关系。在奥斯瓦尔德夫人的头脑中，她们经历过非常相似的事情。
I'm not unhappy, Jean. You can see I'm not. But really, I am a mother in history. I'm all over the world. My son's the one accused. History's been made because of him. And here, we have Mrs. Kennedy very well and Marina very well. And here, I'm wondering where my next meal is coming from. And it's almost unbelievable. Sometimes it's almost like a spiritual thing because if you research Jesus Christ's mother, you never heard any more about the mother of Jesus, Mary, after he was crucified on the cross.
我不难过，吉恩。你可以看出我不是。但真的，我是一个历史中的母亲。我遍布世界各地。我的儿子是被告。历史因为他而创造。在这里，肯尼迪夫人和玛丽娜都过得很好。而在这里，我在想下一顿饭从哪来。这简直令人难以置信。有时这几乎像是一种精神上的事情，因为如果你研究耶稣基督的母亲，在他被钉在十字架上之后，你就再也没听过关于耶稣的母亲玛丽的消息了。
At the end of the day, when her driver arrived to pick her up, Jean Stafford decided to leave the tape recorders at Mrs. Oswald's house overnight. They were heavy, and she was coming back the next day anyway. Early the next morning, Stafford lay in bed, dreading her session with Mrs. Oswald. "My impulse was to eliminate the day by taking a sleeping pill," she confessed. While Stafford dawdled in her hotel room, Mrs. Oswald picked up the microphone and started to speak. It was Mother's Day.
在那天结束时，当她的司机到达接她时，吉恩·斯塔福德决定把录音机留在奥斯瓦尔德夫人家过夜。它们太重了，而且她无论如何第二天都要回来。第二天清晨，斯塔福德躺在床上，害怕与奥斯瓦尔德夫人的会面。“我的冲动是吃一片安眠药来消除这一天，”她承认。当斯塔福德在酒店房间磨蹭时，奥斯瓦尔德夫人拿起麦克风开始说话。那是母亲节。
Jean, you left the tape recorders yesterday afternoon in my home, which was Saturday, so that we could work again about an hour today. Upon waking up this morning, and it being Mother's Day, I've decided that in defense of myself and my son, Lee Harvey Oswald, I would put a little something on the tape. I sincerely hope that you will find it newsworthy and print it.
吉恩，你昨天下午把录音机留在了我家，那是周六，这样我们今天可以再工作一个小时。今天早上醒来，而且又是母亲节，我决定为了捍卫我自己和我的儿子李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德，我要在磁带上加点东西。我真诚地希望你会发现它具有新闻价值并发表出来。
Mrs. Oswald began reading from The Warren Report, page 378, which describes how she left Lee home alone a lot when she had a job selling insurance. "This is not true," she exclaimed. From there, she pointed out that telling Lee not to talk to strangers did not make him a loner and offered menus of the nutritious dinners she cooked for her family, such as spaghetti and meatballs. "This," Jean Stafford writes, "is what she witnessed as her car crept up the street in a rainstorm."
奥斯瓦尔德夫人开始朗读《沃伦报告》第378页，其中描述了当她从事卖保险的工作时，如何经常让李一个人待在家里。“这不是真的，”她惊呼道。从那里，她指出告诉李不要与陌生人交谈并不意味着他是个孤独者，并列出了她为家人烹饪的营养晚餐菜单，比如意大利面和肉丸。“这，”吉恩·斯塔福德写道，“就是当她的车在雨中慢慢驶过街道时所目睹的一切。”
Somewhere in the neighborhood, a voice, much amplified, was blaring. "I thought at first it was coming from the soundtrack of a political candidate on a mobile stump or from one advertising an American Legion carnival. But as I got out of the car, I realized that it was pouring out of Mrs. Oswald's house and that the voice belonged to her." Mrs. Oswald was playing back the tape she had made that morning, doing the work she'd devoted her life to, answering questions no one had asked, piling detail on detail, amplifying her voice in a quiet neighborhood where nobody seemed to be listening.
在附近的某个地方，一个声音被极大地放大，轰鸣着。“我起初以为它来自流动竞选演讲的政治候选人的原声带，或者是广告美国军团嘉年华的录音。但当我下车时，我意识到它正从奥斯瓦尔德夫人的房子里倾泻而出，那个声音属于她。”奥斯瓦尔德夫人正在回放她那天早上制作的磁带，做着她毕生致力于的工作，回答没有人问过的问题，细节堆砌细节，在一个安静的街区放大她的声音，那里似乎没有人听着。
Really and truly, as I say, this is Mother's Day I'm taping. And I'm very proud of the role that I played as a mother.
真的，诚实地说，正如我所说，这是母亲节我在录音。我很骄傲作为一个母亲所扮演的角色。
This American Life producer Susan Burton.
《美国生活》制作人苏珊·伯顿。
Act Three, You Don't Have To Be An Einstein. After he died, here are some of the unfortunate things that happened to physicist Albert Einstein. He started showing up as a comic character in Hollywood films. He appeared in Pepsi ads with that evil little girl. And until very recently, his very brain was on the loose without his family's consent in the unauthorized possession of the doctor who did the autopsy, a man named Thomas Harvey. Mike Paterniti recently took a cross country road trip with Doctor Harvey and the brain. At one point, in search of the global epicenter of those who have attached themselves to Einstein after the physicist's death, Mike headed to Japan.
第三章，“你不必非得是爱因斯坦”。他死后，这里发生了一些不幸的事情，关于物理学家阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦。他开始以滑稽形象出现在好莱坞电影中。他和那个邪恶的小女孩一起出现在百事可乐的广告中。直到最近，他的大脑一直在未经家人同意的情况下，被执行尸检的医生托马斯·哈维擅自占有。迈克·帕特尼蒂最近和哈维医生以及那颗大脑进行了一次横跨全国的公路旅行。在某一时刻，为了寻找那些在物理学家死后依附于爱因斯坦的人的全球中心，迈克前往日本。
Kenji Sugimoto is an obscure math professor at a place called Kinki University in Osaka, Japan. He is also one of the most prolific collectors of Einsteiniana in the world. When I find him at his office at Kinki, he's wearing a green tie with Einstein's face on it. He offers me a seat, then realizes it's occupied by a huge canvas, a crude, though heartfelt portrait of Einstein in later life. He briefly admires it, by way of registering its importance, and sets it on the floor next to a trembling tower of Einstein books.
杉本健二是一位在日本大阪近畿大学教书的默默无闻的数学教授。他也是世界上收藏爱因斯坦物品最丰富的人之一。当我在近畿大学的办公室找到他时，他戴着一条印有爱因斯坦脸的绿色领带。他让我坐下，然后意识到那儿被一块巨大的帆布占用了，那是一幅粗糙但充满深情的爱因斯坦晚年肖像。他简要地欣赏了一下，以示对其重要性的认同，并将其放在地板上，旁边是一堆摇摇欲坠的爱因斯坦书籍。
He produces a cache of black-and-white photographs, marking Einstein's progress through Japan during his 1922 trip here. These are among his most prized possessions. Einstein, wearing a heavy overcoat and wide-brimmed hat against the December chill, looking more exorcist than physicist. Einstein jamming on a piano. Einstein standing before a chalkboard scrawled with inscrutable equations, a nimbus of numbers about his head, under the rapt gaze of his audience. As we riffle through the photographs, the professor runs his fingers over them as if reading Braille, traces the path on which Einstein is seen walking, gently touches the great scientist's head.
他拿出了一批黑白照片，标记了爱因斯坦在1922年日本之行期间的足迹。这些是他最珍贵的藏品之一。爱因斯坦穿着厚重的大衣和宽边帽抵御十二月的寒冷，看起来更像是驱魔人而不是物理学家。爱因斯坦在钢琴上即兴演奏。爱因斯坦站在写满深奥公式的黑板前，数字光环笼罩着他的头，在观众着迷的注视下。当我们翻阅这些照片时，教授用手指划过它们，仿佛在读盲文，追踪爱因斯坦行走的路径，轻轻触碰这位伟大科学家的头部。
We're interrupted by a knock at the door, three sharp raps, and then in step the polished wingtips of a man introduced to me only as Abe, Kenji's good friend and secretary of the Einstein World Congress, an organization founded by Sugimoto to further cooperation among Einstein scholars and enthusiasts as well as to establish the first-ever Albert Einstein museum. Abe is dressed in a very sharp, shiny suit, the coral color of the sea off Bora Bora. Sugimoto and Abe stand amid the clutter of Sugimoto's office, talking turkey. They need $3 million to make the museum work. And most of all, they need the support of the powerful Mr. Kobe, the director of Kinki University and the man who apparently can make it rain gold doubloons if he likes the cut of your jib.
我们被敲门声打断，三声急促的敲击，然后进来了一位穿着考究尖头鞋的男士，他只被介绍为阿部，健二的好朋友，也是爱因斯坦世界大会的秘书长，该组织由杉本创立，旨在促进爱因斯坦学者和爱好者之间的合作，并建立首个阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦博物馆。阿部穿着一套非常时髦、闪亮的西装，是波拉波拉岛海域的那种珊瑚色。杉本和阿部站在杉本凌乱的办公室中间，谈论着生意。他们需要300万美元才能让博物馆运作起来。最重要的是，他们需要近畿大学校长、那个显然只要喜欢你的行事风格就能让你金币雨从天而降的强大神户先生的支持。
Abe is here to join us for lunch with the powerful Mr. Kobe. And when Sugimoto consults his wristwatch and realizes we're late, both World Congress members suddenly look stricken, compose themselves, straighten their respective ties, slap each other on the back as a kind of psych, then lead me out of the office and up the elevator. When I first spy the powerful Mr. Kobe, he is sitting behind a large desk, chatting on the phone. He is a larger man than either Sugimoto or Abe, with big hands and an impassive face. He has a way of looking through a person to the skeleton reality of who you really are. He gives me a grave look and a bone-crushing handshake.
阿部是来加入我们与强大的神户先生的午餐的。当杉本查看手表并意识到我们迟到了，两位世界大会成员突然看起来很受打击，稳住情绪，挺直领带，互相拍拍背作为一种鼓劲，然后带我走出办公室，乘电梯上去。当我第一次窥见强大的神户先生时，他正坐在大桌子后面，在电话上聊天。他比杉本或阿部身材魁梧，双手巨大，面无表情。他有一种透视人本质骨架的能力。他给了我一个严肃的表情和一次骨头都要碎掉的握手。
I'm introduced as an American scholar though he doesn't even pretend to buy that nonsense. In his presence, even Sugimoto is more subdued, a bit more manly. There's some tough guy small talk, and the powerful Mr. Kobe's voice is a low, commanding rumble like a tank unit running through an abandoned village. Everything rides behind it.
我被介绍为美国学者，尽管他甚至没有假装相信那番鬼话。在他面前，连杉本都变得拘谨了，男人味了一些。有一些强硬派的闲聊，强大的神户先生的声音是一种低沉、具有指挥性的隆隆声，就像一支坦克部队穿过废弃的村庄。一切都骑在它后面。
With the food, the mood lightens. Abe lays out a business plan for the Einstein museum. And Sugimoto breaks in every now and again with a statement, uttered seriously, that seems utterly unserious. With each intervention, the powerful Mr. Kobe lets out a low, Lurch-like growl, as if stricken by indigestion, then goes back to chain smoking. When the powerful Mr. Kobe gazes out at the Kusunoki Mountains, he seems to be considering the cost benefit neon-light proposition of Kinki University's Einstein museum, a place where day and night, the citizens of the world will stand on line, pockets bursting with Yen.
随着食物上来，气氛变得轻松了。阿部提出了爱因斯坦博物馆的商业计划。杉本每隔一段时间就会插话，以严肃的口吻陈述一个似乎完全不严肃的声明。每次插话，强大的神户先生都会发出一种低沉的、像拉奇那样的咆哮，仿佛遭受了消化不良，然后回去继续抽烟。当强大的神户先生凝视着楠山时，他似乎在考虑近畿大学爱因斯坦博物馆的成本效益霓虹灯提议，一个日日夜夜全世界公民都会站着排队、口袋里塞满日元的地方。
Next up is the teacher's lounge, where Kenji seats me on a naugahyde couch, then rushes from the room and returns with a videotape, a 1994 BBC documentary about Kenji's journey to America to find Doctor Thomas Harvey and Einstein's brain. Kenji refers to it as "my movie." In it, he crisscrosses the country on a bizarre, month-long odyssey from the corridors of Princeton Hospital to a succession of humdrum Midwestern towns, dogging anyone who might know anything about Einstein's brain until he finds Doctor Harvey in Lawrence, Kansas, an old man sleeping on a sofa bed in a cramped apartment.
接下来是教师休息室，健二让我坐在人造革沙发上，然后冲出房间，回来时带了一盘录像带，一部1994年的BBC纪录片，关于健二去美国寻找托马斯·哈维医生和爱因斯坦大脑的旅程。健二称之为“我的电影”。在影片中，他横跨全国，经历了一次离奇的、为期一个月的奥德赛，从普林斯顿医院的走廊到一系列平淡无奇的中西部小镇，追踪任何可能了解爱因斯坦大脑的人，直到他在堪萨斯州劳伦斯找到了哈维医生，一个睡在狭窄公寓沙发床上的老人。
When Kenji requests a piece of Einstein's brain, Harvey takes a steak knife from a kitchen drawer, places his hand in a glass cookie jar full of brain, and fishes out a slab, plopping it on a wood cutting board, where he silently begins slicing.
当健二要求一块爱因斯坦的大脑时，哈维从厨房抽屉里拿出一把牛排刀，将手伸进装满大脑的玻璃饼干罐里，钓出一块，把它甩在木砧板上，然后默默地开始切片。
And it is here where the off-screen Kenji, the real Kenji, intervenes. Impatiently, emphatically, he plunks a white canister on the table before me, switching off the television, then pacing around the table a couple of times. Then he rolls up his sleeves, loosens the knot of his tie, and unlids it. Inside the canister is a tea tin, a purple Twinings container, flavor Lapsang Souchong. Kenji gently removes it and, again, pries off another lid. Here, he reaches slowly into its dark gullet and pulls out two wide-mouthed, plastic pill containers. These, he ceremoniously sets on the table, as if he's handling two Faberge eggs.
正是这里，屏幕外的健二，真正的健二，干预了。他不耐烦地、强调性地把一个白色罐子重重地放在我面前的桌子上，关掉电视，然后在桌子周围踱步两次。然后他卷起袖子，松开领带结，打开盖子。罐子里是一个茶叶盒，一个紫色的川宁容器，正山小种风味。健二轻轻地把它拿出来，再次撬开另一个盖子。在这里，他慢慢地伸进黑暗的喉咙，拿出了两个宽口的塑料药瓶。他仪式般地把这些放在桌子上，仿佛在处理两颗法贝热彩蛋。
When he screws off these last lids, we both draw close, expectantly. "Einstein brain," says Kenji, beaming broadly, gesturing to the formaldehyde pools in each container. The smell catches me first. I come forward, breathing solely through my mouth. What floats in the liquid looks less like a brain than a sneeze, just gobby pieces of phlegm.
当他旋开最后这些盖子时，我们俩都充满期待地靠了过去。“爱因斯坦的大脑，”健二满脸笑容地说，指着每个容器里的甲醛池。气味首先抓住了我。我向前倾，完全用嘴呼吸。液体里漂浮的东西看起来不像大脑，倒更像是一个喷嚏，只是一团团粘稠的痰。
"Shono," Kenji blurts, in his excitement, momentarily abandoning his English. "Cerebellum," shaped like a bonsai tree. "Piece of Einstein's brain bring harmony," he says. "My spirit belongs to Einstein's brain." He riffles through a Japanese-English dictionary that he has brought with him from his office. "Shugo," he says. "Divine protection." Then "ishiki." "Consciousness, oneself." We sit in silence.
“小脑，”健二兴奋地脱口而出，暂时放弃了他的英语。“像盆景树的形状。”他说。“爱因斯坦的大脑碎片带来和谐，”他说。“我的精神属于爱因斯坦的大脑。”他翻阅着从办公室带来的日-英词典。“守护，”他说。“神圣的保护。”然后是“意识”。“自我。”我们坐在沉默中。
And after a time, I move closer to the floating brain bits again. "But what does it mean," I ask him, both repulsed and fascinated. Kenji furrows his brow, starts to speak, then stops, then starts again, considers the question at length, trying to forge the perfect grammatical sentence. "To be or not to be," he says. "This is what Einstein's brain is all about."
过了一会儿，我再次靠近那些漂浮的大脑碎片。“但这意味着什么，”我问他，既排斥又着迷。健二皱起眉头，开始说话，然后停住，然后再次开始，长时间思考这个问题，试图编造出完美的语法句子。“生存还是毁灭，”他说。“这就是爱因斯坦大脑的全部意义。”
After seeing the brain, there is nothing to do but celebrate by going to a karaoke lounge, a favorite haunt of Kenji and his colleagues. There are seven or eight ladies who attend to the clientele, a collection of suited men in various states of besotment. I'm introduced to Miss Michiko Miyata, the matron of the lounge. A short, friendly, over-busy woman who employs a quiet arsenal of hand signals, whispers, rib-prodding, and foot-stamping, all with a smile to keep her girls in line and on the ready. The hostesses have names like Jun and Kyoko. And one 19-year-old Chinese singer, with eyes of soft, brown liquid, is called Lily.
看完大脑后，除了去卡拉OK酒吧庆祝之外别无他法，这是健二和同事们最喜欢的消遣。有七八位女士负责招待顾客，一群处于不同醉酒状态的穿西装的男士。我被介绍给三千代宫田小姐，酒吧的女主管。一位矮小、友好、过于忙碌的女士，她用一系列安静的手势、耳语、戳肋骨和跺脚，全都带着微笑来让女孩们保持秩序和准备就绪。女招待们有叫润和京子的名字。而一位有着柔软棕色液体眼睛的19岁中国歌手叫莉莉。
Of all people, the powerful Mr. Kobe is here too, wearing his Noh mask of no expression, sitting in a dark corner, accepting visits from his minions, chain smoking Omar Sharif cigarettes, and making neat work of his whiskey. He is here, I'm told, six nights a week, all except Sunday. The powerful Mr. Kobe regards me from behind a wraith of smoke, but shows no flicker of recognition. The set of his face is severe, a perpetual frown from the heavy, heavy weight of his world.
在所有人中，强大的神户先生也在这里，戴着他的无表情能剧面具，坐在黑暗的角落里，接受手下的造访，抽着奥马尔·谢里夫牌香烟，干脆利落地处理他的威士忌。我被告知，他一周六个晚上都在这里，除了周日。强大的神户先生透过一缕烟雾看着我，但没有流露出任何认出的闪烁。他面部的设置很严肃，因为他世界沉重的负担而带着永久的愁容。
One of the most pleasant surprises of the night is that Kenji has a beautiful Wayne Newton voice, a supple manliness in the notes he sings to a syrupy Japanese favorite, "Blue Airport," the tale of two lovers separated by a plane trip of some sort, thankfully reunited when the return ticket is executed. He sways, he closes a fist to show pain. After some point in the evening, everyone is sloshed and beginning on a maudlin march to some unknown destination.
当晚最令人愉快的惊喜之一是健二有着美丽的韦恩·牛顿式嗓音，他在唱一首充满糖浆味的日本流行歌曲《蓝色机场》时展现出一种柔韧的男人味，这是一个关于两名恋人因某种飞机旅行而分开的故事，幸运的是，在回程票执行时他们重逢。他摇摆，他握紧拳头展示痛苦。当晚晚些时候，每个人都喝得烂醉，开始向某个未知的目的地蹒跚前行。
The hostess named Lily has sung with a slew of men. And now, I'm told, that this is Lily's last evening with the troops after three years of singing at this lounge, of being in all of their lives. She is going back to China in the morning. It is very late when, at the proddings of the patrons, Lily picks up one of the cordless mics and begins a slow, sad goodbye song in Chinese. She is unquestionably stunning, long, black hair, full lips, a thin back partially revealed by her gown.
那个叫莉莉的招待员和许多男人一起唱过歌。现在，我被告知，这是莉莉在三年的驻唱生涯后，在这一酒吧驻唱的最后一个晚上，这三年里她存在于所有人的生活中。她明天早上就要回中国了。天色已晚，在常客的催促下，莉莉拿起其中一个无线麦克风，开始用中文唱一首缓慢、悲伤的离别歌。她无疑是令人惊叹的，长长的黑发，丰满的嘴唇，礼服露出的薄薄的背部。
As she sweetly finds the notes, as she throws herself into one last song, I realize people are weeping-- the hostesses, the men, Kenji. And Lily, who has been doing just fine, begins to falter, realizes that this is it, that her life lived at night in the cozy confines of this purple-lit lounge, among so many men who have become like fathers to her, among her fellow sisters, who have watched her become a woman, this life of money and freedom and joy will so cruelly end with a short flight to Beijing and the prison of her family.
当她甜美地找到音符，当她投入最后的一首歌中时，我意识到人们在流泪——女招待们，男士们，健二。而一直表现得很好的莉莉开始动摇，意识到就是这样了，她在紫色灯光酒吧舒适范围内度过的夜晚生活，在这么多已经成为她父亲般角色的男人中间，在那些看着她长成女人的姐妹中间，这种金钱、自由和快乐的生活将残酷地终结于一趟飞往北京的短途航班和她家庭的监狱中。
And then she is blubbering, honest wails that she tries to suppress, her grief monstrously revealed in the professional spotlight. The music carries on without her, mournfully, slowly, but with a trace of seeming malice now. Though she is trying not to lose face, she can only eke out a word or two of each verse in an attempt to catch up, bent at the waist, covering her eyes.
然后她就在啜泣，她试图压抑真实的哭声，她的悲伤在专业聚光灯下极其怪诞地暴露。音乐在没有她的情况下继续，忧郁、缓慢，但现在带着一丝恶意。尽管她试图不丢脸，但在试图赶上时，她只能勉强挤出一两个字，弯着腰，遮住眼睛。
In her last act as a karaoke lounge singer, she is dying on stage. A wave of discomfort washes over the room. But then suddenly, just as one hostess begins to rush toward the crumpled girl, a voice rises out of nowhere like a large-winged bird. Out of the shadows in the room, on a second cordless mic, a strong, full-timbred voice, deep and sure, conveying with each note the ache and pathos of goodbye, the rent feelings of everyone in the room, the death of this era, the Lily years.
在作为卡拉OK酒吧歌手的最后一次表演中，她在舞台上崩溃了。一阵不安涌上房间。但就在一位女招待开始冲向那个瘫倒的女孩时，一个声音如一只大翅膀的鸟突然从虚无中升起。在房间的阴影里，在第二个无线麦克风上，一个强有力、音色饱满的声音，深沉而确定，用每一个音符传达着离别的痛楚和悲悯，房间里每个人的破裂感情，这个时代的死亡，莉莉的岁月。
There is so much emotion in it, a remarkable lifetime of feeling, really, and yet such strength that even Lily looks up from where she is kneeling, a single tear sparkling on her cheek.
里面有太多的情感，真的，非凡的一生感悟，却又有着如此的力量，以至于连跪在那里的莉莉都抬起了头，一颗眼泪在她脸颊上闪烁。
And rising from his table, stepping into the spotlight is-- impossible-- the powerful Mr. Kobe. He stands before Lily in his well-tailored suit though he doesn't offer her a hand. He just sings. Lily, looking up to him, gains her balance, rises from the floor, and begins to sing again too. And he carries her right to the end. And everybody is bawling.
从桌子旁站起，走进聚光灯下的是——不可思议——强大的神户先生。他站在莉莉面前，穿着剪裁精良的西装，尽管他没向她伸出手。他只是唱歌。莉莉抬头看着他，重新获得平衡，从地板上站起来，也开始再次歌唱。他带着她唱到了最后。每个人都在嚎啕大哭。
When the song is over, Lily smiles, then turns to the powerful Mr. Kobe and bows to him. He nods stiffly, retires to his table, and then later, when she visits him one last time, he presents her with an envelope full of money. Even as formality and reticence slowly reassert themselves, something has happened here that no one will forget. It's one of the most honest acts of love I've ever witnessed.
当歌唱结束时，莉莉微笑着，然后转身向强大的神户先生鞠躬。他僵硬地点点头，退回到他的桌子旁，后来当她最后一次拜访他时，他递给她一个装满钱的信封。即使形式和矜持慢慢地重新确立，这里已经发生了一些没人会忘记的事情。这是我见证过的最真诚的爱的行为之一。
Out in the early morning street, six of us pile into a cab, Kenji, me, and some of his inebriated friends. No one says anything. We just watch as the neon lights of downtown Osaka fall into the melancholy swirl of the river. During the war, after Tokyo was firebombed, American fighter jets attacked Osaka, destroying much of the downtown where we now drive. Kenji himself was born in the short years after his own hometown, Nagasaki, was obliterated.
在清晨的街上，我们六个人挤进出租车，健二，我，还有他的一些醉酒朋友。没人说话。我们只是看着大阪市中心的霓虹灯坠入河流的忧郁漩涡中。战争期间，东京被火烧后，美国战斗机袭击了大阪，摧毁了我们现在开车经过的大部分市中心。健二本人出生在他自己的家乡长崎被抹去后的那几年里。
His parents somehow survived the horrors of Einstein's most dubious legacy, the bomb. It's only when we come to where I'm staying, only after I've gotten out of the cab and placed a hand on its closed door, that Kenji comes down from some faraway place in his mind. "To be, Mr. Michael," he says. "It's much better to be."
他的父母以某种方式在爱因斯坦最可疑的遗产——炸弹的恐怖中幸存下来。只有当我们到达我住的地方，只有在我下车并把手放在关闭的车门上后，健二才从他头脑中某个遥远的地方走下来。“存在，迈克尔先生，”他说。“存在要好得多。”
Mike Paterniti reading an excerpt from his book Driving Mr. Albert.
迈克·帕特尼蒂朗读他书《驾驶艾伯特先生》的节选。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia who says that he is not defensive. You just have to remember.
WBEZ管理监督托雷·马拉蒂亚，他说他并不防卫。你只需记住。
I am in 26 volumes of the president's report which is all over the world.
我身处总统报告的26卷里，这些报告遍布世界各地。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。